you've seen through ticket sales that
there is still a huge audience for a
Shania Twain show but when you found out
just through listening to fans or the
appearances that you've done so far that
there is still a massive audience for
new Shania Twain music was there relief
was there because you often wonder you
know are the people still there if I go
on this will they still be there and I
never take that for granted
because I just think that would be
foolish and I wouldn't say that I worry
about that because it isn't necessarily
something that I can control but I care
about that sure you know I do care I
care that I write music that fans love
and that they can relate to I do care
that I make quality music and I care
about the standard of work that I create
yeah how would your son know 15:15 going
to be 16 soon yes okay and then what is
it like to try and release a new record
while having a kid almost 16 years old
at home dealing with sort of that and we
talked to me this is I mean you haven't
released a record having to deal with
that kind of stuff before
well I time everything around his life
your schedules which every working
mother knows what that's all about
does he appreciate that as much as you
would like him to I think he does oh
really yeah he's very supportive not
just an amateur enough now he's he's
quite mature he he really does
appreciate it my dude I try to do it all
well you know I'm quite traditional as a
parent I like sit-down dinners I like
cooking breakfast on Sunday mornings I
like you know I start making his lunch
and doing the school run so I'm just I'm
very involved my love family and I'm at
home but I love my work as well and the
way to balance in now in the moment is
to plan around summers and and school
schedules and so on which takes a lot of
events preparation but now it you know
in the summer he's at shifting traveling
on his own now he
off to Europe and and working in studios
and and then you know he'll travel with
his dad and go around to some football
games and while I'm you know whose music
bearing my album relief right so he is
musical though yes yes did you encourage
that or no I did I didn't discourage it
I was very neutral okay I wanted him to
find it on his own
he doesn't want to perform he loves to
arrange and compose and produce right
that's what he loves to do
that's incredible when you the ideas of
having to go back out on the road again
having already put it away
that means the travel the hotel is the
the performing is very different than
the touring yes well the touring is just
taxing because of schedule and the just
traveling siren you're going in and out
time zones and my voice isn't
particularly delicate okay my voice has
a lot of stamina I've never had a
problem there but this new issue that
I've this issue that I've got with the
with the nerves in an alluring Joel
weakness that's there takes a lot more
physical preparation okay so it's it's
more on the athletic side that it's
tiring so I have to warm up for an hour
and a half and then I've got a 90-minute
show on top of it it's long yeah I talk
to you when you had just turned 50 and
you had said your goal was to release
this record while you were still 50 oh I
know it's two and a half years to do
this out and I'm going to be 52 when the
album comes out um comes out that's okay
that's okay
yeah you are there there you also had
said that you did not start worrying
about 50 until you were 49 at the last
minute it all sort of it also have hit
you now that 50 has happened yeah see ya
spontaneous emotions I don't like living
too far in the future like I dare you
you know why we're about 50 when you're
45 right so do you still have that
attitude now that 50 has come and gone
yeah told ya I'm going I'm using engines
ah yeah
I have no problem with the aging thing
are you still setting goals for
accomplishments that you want to
question its gateways maybe I should
stay away from doing that
I really am more of a go-with-the-flow
kind of person yeah and I don't like
locking myself in locking myself into
things makes me anxious really yeah
because I well I think there's like so
many things to do and I overload myself
so I need to get myself room and I like
to be spontaneous anyway yeah I think
that too much structure kills creativity
really I've got to strike a balance
there did you learn that early on I
think so I have a my brain just works a
little bit peripherally yeah a lot
peripherally actually so I need I need I
need a broad scope of everything and
then I narrow in on the on the focus
right if I'm narrowed in from the
beginning that's it I feel like you know
like I feel claustrophobic so my brain
needs room when you started sitting down
when it was known that you were going to
be writing a new album did people come
out from everywhere who wanted to help
you with this it was I'm feeling the
love list of collaborators and producers
and did you get that where people like I
would love to be a part of this it has
been a long time and this needs to
happen I'm still getting that even when
the records finish and I'm like oh I
wish you would've told me that before I
would have loved to have you on the ELMO
so it's it's been really a lot of people
are going to anticipating a new album so
it's industry wise it's been very good
that way yeah the musicians all you know
happy to play on and it really really
good spirit around and all of that and
treating it with importance which I
really appreciated
yeah and yeah they treated it with
importance and respect which just made
me feel like I was that you know
everybody was looking out for me and
they wanted the best for me and was you
know very sincere and genuine so it was
supportive yeah a supportive experience
helped me hear was there a point where
prints free
tout to you yes he was the first person
to reach out through loser yes and I he
was the first person when I was still in
the middle of I was still only separated
at that point I hadn't I was not nowhere
near getting my voice together yet I had
no confidence in the voice yet and I
have no songs that were written and
ready so he was way ahead of me right
and that I mean it was unfortunate in
the way that you know then he you know
obviously was unwell and and you know we
know all what what happened in the end
but the fortunate side is that I got to
meet him exchange ideas talk to him and
that I'm very grateful for right yeah do
people want you now to sing on their
tracks oh yeah I and and and you know
the co-writing is something that now I
think I'll get back into now that I've
taken this moment to I guess reacquaint
myself with myself and Jorge standing
alone yeah I just needed to do it for me
but yeah I look now I look forward to
cooperating I think we I know it will be
really fun